WESLEY CHUN: Well, welcome
back to "Serverless Migration
Station," where we
show Google Cloud
users one specific
migration they
can take to
modernize their apps.
This is the video for
module 1, focusing
on helping App Engine users to
switch from webapp2 to Flask,
a popular web framework
in the Python community.
Doing so opens the door to
additional modernization
techniques.
Hi.
I'm Wesley from Google here
to lead your journey, joined
by my colleague, Martin, and
our little friend, Porter,
who will take you from
point A to point B.
MARTIN OMANDER: Hey, Wes.
Happy to help.
But why are we
focusing on webapp2?
I thought App Engine
supported many web frameworks.
WESLEY CHUN: Yes, that is
absolutely true, Martin.
While users can use other
frameworks with App Engine,
webapp2 comes bundled
with App Engine,
making it the default
choice for many developers,
and unfortunately, not
supported in Python 3.
By the way, if you've been using
a framework that's not webapp,
you may actually
be in better shape.
App Engine is now a
more flexible platform.
So moving away from bundled
services, like webapp2,
will make users'
apps more portable.
Also, Flask has more users,
it has more resources,
and is better supported.
Flask isn't the only option.
And generally, any
WSGI-compliant framework
that does routing is supported.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK, so I get
it for the web framework.
But what about all those App
Engine bundled service APIs?
WESLEY CHUN: Well, have you
heard of Cloud Datastore
and Cloud Tasks?
Well, they started out as
App Engine Datastore and Task
Queues.
And since then, they've
matured to becoming
their own standalone
cloud products
where you'll find continuing
new features and innovation.
We'll tackle those in
other migration modules,
but this one focuses
just on Flask.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
You said we're going to
migrate a sample app to Flask.
What app?
WESLEY CHUN: Well, in
the module 0 video,
we gave an overview
of the baseline
app we're starting from.
So check it out
if you missed it.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK, I'd like
to follow what you're doing
to the code on my own computer.
Can you point me
to the source code?
WESLEY CHUN: Sure thing, Martin.
Here's the link.
And by the way, the repo
is maintained regularly,
unlike videos, so the
code may be newer there.
Let's pause so all of
you can go clone the repo
or download the zip file.
Got it?
Great.
Let's go to the
computer now and start
migrating that module 0 code and
turn it into the module 1 code.
Let's start from a good place.
Grab the module 0 code from the
repo and deploy to App Engine.
If you've been around,
you're probably
expecting to do
an appcfg update.
There's a newer and more
powerful CLI called gcloud
that comes with the Cloud SDK.
It gives you access
to most Cloud tools,
instead of just one.
So to upload to App Engine,
use gcloud app deploy.
What doesn't change
is that your app
should be deployed and available
around the world in less
than a minute.
Starting with the
application file,
main.py, swap the Flask
imports for webapp2s.
Next, while webapp2
is initialized
at the bottom with
its routing table,
you can do it at
the top with Flask.
Your app is more complex,
but these basic changes
apply regardless.
Next, this app
only has one route,
which goes to MainHandler.
Since we already know this,
you can wipe the table.
But when migrating your app,
don't delete it quite yet.
You'll probably have
many more routes,
which you need to track.
So just comment it out for now
once you get to this point.
There's no change to the
way we access Datastore.
The data model and accompanying
read/write calls stay as-is.
The handler represents the
majority of the affected code.
webapp2 uses the handler classes
and corresponding HTTP methods.
In Flask, a handler is just
a route-decorated function,
like this.
Finally, both frameworks render
the template in a similar way,
so you just switch
to how Flask does it.
With that, you're done
migrating the main application.
For this migration,
app.yaml stays the same.
The index.html template file
is identical to the original
with one minor, but
notable, difference.
The Django-style templates
that webapp2 uses automatically
executes callables, whereas
the Jinja2 templating
system that Flask
uses by default
requires users to
explicitly add parentheses.
The datetime.ctime() call turns
timestamps into human-readable
strings, and that's used in
this app to show when visits
occurred.
Flask also organizes web
templates in a templates folder
by default, so create it and
move index.html into it before
or after your edit
to the ctime() call.
Since Flask isn't
bundled like webapp2,
you must add it to a list
of required packages.
The base [INAUDIBLE]
app didn't have any, so
create a brand new
requirements.txt
file with just Flask.
If you're unfamiliar with
the requirements.txt file,
check out its documentation.
For us, the current
version is 1.12.
For a simple app, you probably
don't need the version.
But in any case, the
repo is maintained
while this video
isn't, meaning you
may see a newer version there.
First-gen App Engine
runtimes required developers
to explicitly bundle
third-party packages.
For our app, it's Flask
and its dependencies.
So run this pip install
command to install them
to the lib folder before
you test or deploy.
A side effect of bundling
third-party packages
is that you need to tell App
Engine where to find them.
So that's what
appengine_config.py is
for, to tell the
system to look in lib.
For your apps, you'll create
this file in the same folder
as your application
code, just like what
we've done with this sample.
The only other files in the repo
are a README and .gcloudignore,
neither of which are critical.
But .gcloudignore is useful in
preventing unnecessary files
to be uploaded.
And that's it.
MARTIN OMANDER: Hey, Wes,
thanks for showing us
how to move to Flask.
Watching this video is great.
But is there a way for me to
do that migration by hand,
on my own time,
on that sample app
before migrating my own code?
WESLEY CHUN: Well, I'm
glad you asked, Martin.
Yes.
In addition to this video, we
have a corresponding Google
codelab.
Codelabs are free, online,
self-paced, hands-on tutorials,
so you can do this same
migration on your own time.
The repo links you to
the codelab, the starting
module 0 code, as well as
the finished module 1 code.
If you get stuck, you
can always go back
to module 0 or
compare your solution
to module 1 to see where you
may have gotten off-course.
For your convenience,
here are the docs
to both frameworks so that
you can compare, and contrast,
and better understand the
differences between them.
MARTIN OMANDER: Now
that you've shown us
how to unlink part of our
app from dedicated App Engine
libraries, like webapp2
framework, what's next, Wes?
WESLEY CHUN: Well the module
0 app used both webapp2
and the NDB library
to talk to Datastore.
Now that we're done
with the framework part,
we're going to be focused on
moving from NDB to Cloud NDB,
so be sure to join us for that.
This is Wesley from Google Cloud
on behalf of Martin and Porter.
Thanks for tuning in today, and
we look forward to seeing you
at the next "Serverless
Migration Station,"
as well as on other
serverless expeditions.